when set canopy what your pee real quick
you can hold it in the hole I shouldn't
read how you actually actually start the
episode that way being a TV up in the
office
Karev level will be through operation
total by ownership middle average ap
high detectors that outdoors average
again this time we're going to oh
there's AJ AJ me in a call
Adriana Vayner sports call that was
exciting
it's good to see Michael bro let's go
downstairs downstairs is where pure
malice if you're not I not subscribe to
peel now dr. Ram she like put the link
right here or PL hey hey super well how
are you good tell me yeah I'm just doing
a little filming [ __ ] it not see what's
going on down here
hey Lisa Buckley how are you oh well I'm
super well hey dude
Wow your hair is legit I really like
that summary you guys like his hair I
like it hey mom how are you hi
parallel to show you something real
quick
as Ryan Harwood when he was 30 pounds
lighter
he still is here it didn't affect me he
actually didn't affect him in the
sensitivity hmm
rare rare opportunity for the rocker I
was adjusting a lot around nominee
office by myself so it's got a little
bit of tour this is the quiet riot room
for your 80s kids
there's Quiet Riot that's it was a
couple of hundred or what the hell's
going on here now I used to be a big ass
table here but that's right Shirley glad
I caught that lays ahead make sure
that's huge
[Music]
let me actually show you around a little
bit since the first time you're here
[Music]
it's right here
[Music]
No
I have one I've one skill I really
understand people and in them in my will
in my act of will it says if the human
race figures out how to measure
emotional intelligence I want to be
scored
that's how deeply I feel it came to me
at a genius level but we don't talk
about that the only people that make the
move care about one thing legacy if you
do not care about legacy
you don't trade on this moment in time
Andy
babban d-roc I've got to figure it out
[Music]
samus's sounds awesome the practicality
of like I'm going to learn a craft this
summer is ludicrous because there's too
many things that are not in control of
that being the situation hence well I
think it's about the people and plus in
reality anything you would learn in six
or eight or ten weeks you're going to
learn in the first 90 days of a job at
this point where you're questioning
everything and you're still so many of
you are still in that place where you're
just checking the box of what the right
thing to do is because that's how you've
been trained for the last 20 years of
your life
this is exactly the time to start
debating it for real because you wake up
in your 32 real quick right we're just
sitting in this is Eric a star he helped
me build wine library he and we were
just sitting in a small cubicle five
seconds ago building this website so it
happens real quick how do you know
combination of being an immigrant and
having a ridiculously big time mom
because I don't and it's like so real I
just I really wish you could have it too
God
confidence right like just not wavering
like just fundamentally not caring about
what anybody else thinks or feeling that
anybody else is impacting me besides
myself but that's what I will do to the
end thanks guys thanks everyone
all right really good how are you my
friend my pleasure
really about 19 years every dad called
me from South Africa Harlan or
fulfilling my show what is your focus
flex only the comedy show which we want
forward-facing they're incredible coming
here now it's a good plan it's funny I
didn't just look at here and then I'm
gonna unload on you probably I got it I
got it I need to get into social yeah ah
yeah you know what you need to do you
need to call in every favor if you if
you if you take a picture every single
goddamn day with some comedians with ten
thousand fifty thousand a hundred
thousand forty thousand five million one
hundred thousand a million if you just
do it every day it will matter and then
if you in between that make good content
you're on your way and that part comes
easy to you because you're successful
comedian thanks for making it happen
real pleasure so let's stay in touch
yeah me anytime is the fire
love it hi hi I'm Jordan ordinary nice
to meet you good to see you guys how are
you yeah commander the coolest thing
about your impact on the world right now
I sent an email here's a guy 23 years of
school so we graduate degrees right
orthodontists this pro school as there
is out there telling this daughter when
she comes back from a week-long program
in Louisville I'd like to figure out
what your future is she see somebody
speak about social media branding and I
say to her if social media branding is
what you want and that's where you want
to go in turn those who are and learn
the business don't go to college you
know and she's fighting me I want to go
to college I'm like you're not going to
college it's like this bizarro where I
was like to exact college is fun I want
to get my courses already so we can
really go find a bunch of good-looking
girls pay the money to go hang out get
and I love it I definitely I can say
like the caring the effect well you know
it's funny about that like or she could
do college the way I did which is like
actually understand that truth
have fun in her sorority what-have-you
but in the time that would have been
like study hours hone her craft right
like she could kind of go to college and
were like there's a version you got to
go to a shitty enough college is just
the truth where you can actually have a
job and have college life like some
colleges will take you out of school
right someone I went there look I
literally went to four classes in my
life so the kid she needs to go to a
shitty enough calm City enough college
that you can still get the college
experience but you eight hours a day to
actually work on like you could have
four years of getting great at social by
literally working if you go to Ohio
State working at some Columbus Ohio
small agency like nine-to-five should be
going to class now hi say will probably
kick you out but like this is literally
my thesis I'm in nor this is like one of
those millions of conversations that now
you've created in homes that didn't
exist I get it we do it I get it
and I'm just like now you're like what
are you talking about that I was crying
we're and where are you now like a
sophomore junior where you like that
i'ma be a legend on my beard I need to
your daddy else I do ordinary people say
going gone crazy much now liar i'ma give
you like a fifty missing me my check was
now fired I never run it from a ruble
only if I got my crop under is my work I
love your girl love your words the
indexable even now a little bit longer
lucky for you my dear here we believably
we get even when I do baby a bottle -
like we really figured it out like I
really know what to do like you could
become unbelievably recognized every
time you walk around Portland like in a
way that would stun you like I don't
know what to say it's basically like I
think a bit more like Lucille Ball and
Bob Hope like when radio went to
television the world still thought a
radio star was bigger than a television
star but it wasn't true and it took
about a decade for people be like [ __ ]
that's basically like Logan and Jake
Paul are way more famous to anybody
under 25 and virtually every other
person you can name it that's it think
about it I think I just saw a head like
that one piece of content can change at
all no seriously like Ken Ferriss wrote
one book that literally launched an
entire career we've got two or three
videos even better bro even better bro
to your point that keynote I gave at the
Javits Center at web 2.0 then went on
YouTube on TED talk changed my career
led to crush it you know it's the one
piece of content but if you have brand
equity but if you have brand equity you
will be fine there is never a bad time
when you believe when you work hard and
when you know what you're doing but you
have to do this is where it's crucial
you have to do what you love because let
me tell you something it gets tough but
if you love it you will win the only way
to succeed now is to be completely
transparent completely everything is
exposed everything you do so your legacy
is your ultimate life it's all you've
got and you can build so much on that
when you would brand equity anything can
happen
written word audio video pictures four
forms of communication have the ability
to do a law I mean it's the best job on
earth it's literally what every every
single 14 year
on earth wants to either be a YouTube
star or an influencer like why wouldn't
you live your life and make money yeah
these are [ __ ] hot I've so many cool
sweet who'da 10 and a half around here
oh you are I don't think I'm learning
you want to thank you tell them no
please well yeah I gotta nail that okay
I'm good at guessing people shoe size
that's a random skill that people don't
realize I have oh so you mean you're
really trying to be a winner yes how do
you mean this is [ __ ] rad so why
don't why don't we think us don't spend
the money so fast like for example that
we should take two interns literally
just DM every single [ __ ] Facebook
culture page and pay them just to share
it yeah like we don't have the we're not
good at the moon who is replicates of an
intervenor
is back to my intern idea we have like a
slush fund of people like the way I roll
the right model is there's five guys and
girls on our team that actually don't
have anything to do other than the thing
of the moment until I take them off the
thing at the moment but like right now
if I have four people that and think
about who they have to be they have to
be more of our claws which is fit to be
completely utterly not fancy and have to
be willing to eat [ __ ] and be like for
example back in the day like when a
Jade's lunch please dress me in the
search engine the one t-shirt so judges
the best thing I did the thing I was
most fun was staying up to 5:00 in the
morning DMing people or whatever that
was all the time emailing blogs randomly
like I think it's cool to now like I'm
going to we really like start setting
once these up to day like Tyler's going
like I think it's I don't care who does
it like it can be like it's the like to
me nothing's smarter right now than
spending 15 hours messaging every
Facebook page that has a million
followers that's a culture page I mean
like hey we have a video we'd like to
share how much control-c control-v
listen to your favorite [ __ ] album
dislike
like I can't wait for my vacation in
August to do that I sort of remind you
guys that's probably why my Instagram
and podcast work because I went on
vacation did that a little bit it was
like this is what we so like we need to
figure out who to how to hire and how to
frame up for people who realize that's
the best thing to do not a wait a minute
I'm a filmmaker rama business
development perfect like I'm like you
know what I mean I'm up like we need
unbelievable amounts of humility to get
done the kind of things I most believe
in because what I most believe in is all
these people right now like I just want
to basically DM people on Facebook so
Gary Vaynerchuk and ass episode 260 of
the askgaryvee show and I'm super fired
up all right tell everybody who you see
sense all right three cents three cents
and I just get three cents okay nobody
has hosted more sports centers than me
okay let's say that one more time
all right nobody male or female has
hosted more sports centers on ESPN than
me and the time cool all right thank you
so much oh you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them
on this episode LFC stops by a be dead
oh yeah bout a half my work
you
[Music]
[Music]